brunch has always been special and
within Black Culture the black church
has played a big role into this
phenomenon of a brunch socially you know
after a long day of church in course of
course you will you know you'd be hungry
and and want to go eat but in in recent
years we're starting to see
um you know black brunch goers
especially younger Millennials kind of
put their own twist on it and we're
seeing
um you know essentially what a lot of
folks are referring to as a day party
where people are going out you know
having a nice brunch having drinks more
of like a party type of scene I noticed
that Houston was a hotbed of this
activity from people traveling out of
town uh to locals you know wanting to
again engage in brunch and then on the
flip side entrepreneurs especially black
ones uh either starting new restaurants
or making
um you know adjustments to their current
restaurants to put a greater emphasis on
black and so I wanted to see it
firsthand I got down there and I saw you
know
several spots where the lines were like
two to three hours to get in
um people dressed you know to the nines
on uh you know Saturday at 11 and a few
of the places that are are big down
there in terms of brunch one is The
Breakfast Club uh founded by by Marcus
Davis
[Music]
oh my title yeah titles are such a lie
for me but if I have to have one it's
chief steward
all right this I believe
entrepreneurship is about being
entrusted and this is something that the
community has entrusted me with and so
um I have a responsibility of doing
what's right with it and we started this
in 2001 September October 2001 almost 21
years ago his I guess specialty with a
catfish and grits uh he he lovingly
referred to it as the you know catfish
as the uh the the stake of the lake and
you know he really has built a
reputation for himself and really made
this
um a tourist destination if you will
within Houston I spent some time talking
to Marcus while I was down there and
this is what he had to say
in 1999 when I started working on this
concept I looked and saw that there was
a wide open market in terms of breakfast
a wide open market in terms of breakfast
breakfast with substance and wide open
concept of market in terms of sexy
breakfast
foreign
and so as a result of the market being
wide open you know my definition of
Entrepreneurship is filling a void in
the marketplace that the marketplace is
calling for consciously or
subconsciously and there was this huge
void not only in Midtown Houston Houston
as a whole and as I looked even further
there was a board across the country
so as a result
jumped in got it started and I've done a
little homework to see what people
wanted what people needed what people
were asking for and what people weren't
asking for but still
would enjoy
and it was
you know
this crazy thing we call
breakfast and brunch it's a very homey
uh type of restaurants and it has an
old-fashioned feel the the seats are are
a little worn I think that's on purpose
it kind of adds to the aesthetic and I
think Marcus Marcus embodies that you
know as an entrepreneur as well Marcus
is very very energetic very Lively and I
think that what really shines through
through
Marcus is just his you know his passion
for his community his passion for black
culture and the idea is that
um you know this is built by black
people primarily for black people to
feel comfortable but everybody's welcome
and so my thought was
why not do this during the day
why not do this every day our goal was
to create nice warm walls right with
great black art on there while John
Coltrane and Miles Davis is piping
through the speakers and then bam hit
you with the pork chops we we go through
you know hundreds if not thousands of
pounds of grits and chicken wings
of chicken a month a week sorry we're
gonna do 100 pounds of drinking a week
so we up until you know every quarter
you know we do a few thousand by the
time we get to the end of the year you
know we have ten thousand plus
when you look at his business which is
20 years old it's become
um it's really become a Cornerstone of
the entrepreneurial scene within Houston
a lot of people there other
entrepreneurs I spoke to
you know give their respects and pay
homage to uh to The Breakfast Club and
I've even talked and spoken with other
entrepreneurs in different cities who
who said Marcus has inspired them as
well it's like wow and then you know
I've realized the impact that we've had
across the city across the state Across
the Nation in inspiring folks to go into
restaurant
Breakfast Brunch make it live make it
appealing make it sexy it reinforces
keep doing what you've been doing a word
of caution entrepreneurs when you allow
competition to dictate who you are who
you become and you're no longer yourself
right now that doesn't mean don't evolve
that doesn't mean don't innovate
but do it as a result of being an
entrepreneur not as a result of
with somebody else may do I enjoy it
right I'm a I'm a competitive person
right uh so I enjoy engaging
in the competition I enjoy engaging the
competition for the sake of growth for
everyone
I'm clear about what a rising tide does
it lifts all boats right and so I would
be
hypocritical if I wasn't interested
interested in the growth and the success
of other black businesses right
um
because again it's what lifts The Deen
of the oppressor off of the neck The
Breakfast Club is considered one of the
Pioneers in terms of black restaurants
and that focus on brunch in Houston
Lucille's is another uh
I guess Elder restaurant as well they
were started about 10 years ago their
chef is is uh their founder is Chris
Williams he's also a chef Chris was not
in town when I was in Houston he was
actually in Canada getting ready to open
up another restaurant my sense is that
he's very methodical he's strategic
um he keeps a post on on market trends
and I think the thing that really
stood out is is that he values keeping
that entrepreneurial Legacy
strong within his family uh again that
was started with is his great
grandmother
Lucille he has other expansion plans as
well and so
um yeah he's you know he
he's
you know an entrepreneur who who really
um you know it's not just not just
focused on the numbers but focused on
the experience I got a chance to to
connect with him on video
um and Christopher what he had to say
I don't want to say that it's simple
but it's it's the the
you incur the least amount of risk doing
brunch just because the nature of the
ingredients that you're using
Financial Risk because you're using eggs
flour orange juice champagne
like those are the basic things right it
makes sense just from a financial
perspective to focus on a brunch thing
because the cost of Entry is so much
lower cost of the cost of sustainability
is so much lower because you're just
dealing with small cheaper ingredients
and then the challenge is is to make
them delicious to make them beautiful
and to make them uh consistently you
don't really have to you know reinvent
the wheel like you know you have to do
for your dinner menu like you really got
to make your statement brunches you just
need to be consistent you need to be
well priced and you need to have a good
Ambiance and great services to stay in
it six months ago they said you know
what we're doing it Saturdays and
Sundays let's try to let's try to see
what the crowd is like on Fridays and so
they ditched their lunch menu
replaced it with a brunch menu and sales
are up 40 percent
from again from essentially brunch
versus lunch with the pandemic
um Works our working life has changed
which is why you know you're seeing more
people
uh like Friday that we do Friday brunch
as well because not many people are
working on Fridays anymore at least in
office
um so there's more opportunities for
people to enjoy that day drinking and
all that kind of stuff and again it's um
as people are seeing like as restaurants
are getting hip to it it's good business
sense so it makes good sense to Market
that part of your business
well as you can imagine the restaurant
industry is is already tough you know
the margins aren't super great
um and when you're a black restaurant
tour it can be even tougher
um
you know trying to figure out okay what
you know how do I how do I stay true to
myself but also not isolate anyone
there's historical segregation within
the industry
um Chris talked a little bit about that
to me about
um you know restaurants are still some
of the most segregated places in this in
this country restaurants are probably
segregated businesses out there
if you think about it that's true you
know the only catch-all the only
restaurants you see consistently the
only style of restaurants you see
consistently that brings everybody in
or Mexican restaurants
everybody loves a margarita everybody
loves Taco everybody understands fajitas
everybody's up in that giant and the
price Point's pretty much the same
across the board when you get the higher
higher end spots then you start to see
the the separation again
and I think
I don't know this but I just think it's
probably not good for me to say it but I
that there's the reason why a lot of
restaurants didn't want to participate
in like these you know the Houston
Restaurant Week thing which are
discounted meals and all that kind of
stuff is because they want they didn't
want to compromise their existing
clientele by letting in
um a different as they would see an
element of a different socioeconomic
status but now with this Awakening this
black Awakening and that you know and
the country's Awakening of black
black dollar
they didn't give me this is a it's a
record it's like either you wake up
you get out but honestly like
the more inclusion the better
the better because that means just the
more that people tried the more that
people own that they need to step their
game up like they're out right about it
like this is why we're doing it because
we want to capture those black dollars
and that means that the voice of the
black community has now been elevated
and you're listening you're listening
you have to listen so I I see nothing
but us with that it's all upside with
that this business has been
a community staple right and that's not
just because we're here but because
we've been present right on the
Forefront of issues and equity
inequality right and so
um it triggered us into
doing that speaking up speaking out
letting our voice be heard the other
impact that that George Ford uh murder
had on us is that it it brought about an
Awakening in the minds of
African-Americans about
um
responsibility and opportunity in terms
of building businesses
and that's something that I had preached
for 15 years so I was so excited that
there was this
you know this Awakening of of people who
wanted to support and build our
businesses right
um
and why is that why is that so important
because you show me an oppressed people
and I'll show you a people that are
economically disadvantaged
find me a people that are oppressed that
are wealthy that have great economics
okay
right
so the key to Liberation and here was my
saying during the George Floyd movement
the only way to get the need of the
oppressor off of our neck is through
economics
right and so how did so it gave me an
opportunity to continue to share that
message that building businesses changes
your economic conditions the change of
your economic condition changes laws
it's that simple